god of war is arguably the greatest
PlayStation 4 game ever made remarkable
from start to finish we follow Kratos
and his son at Reyes as they embark on a
journey to scatter the ashes of their
wife and mother
it's an enthralling quest that spans the
nine realms of Midgard and sees
encounters with monsters gods and more
whilst on the surface the plot seems
very simplistic there are several
aspects about the games ending that may
have some players scratching their head
throughout this video I will be
discussing several aspects of the finale
so I highly recommend that you skip this
video for now if you still have certain
side quests that you are yet to discover
with that out the way I'm definition and
this is my ending explained video for
God of War in the game's final fight
Kratos faces off against Balder revealed
to be Freya's son she tried to shield
Balder throughout his life making him
invulnerable to most things however we
do see that upon coming into contact
with mistletoe that Balder is stripped
of his immortality and able to be
finally killed
this explains why Freya was so cautious
over a trace as arrows throughout the
game and attempted to replace them with
ones that would not hurt her son due to
the anguish that his face throughout his
life Balder attempts to murder his
mother Freya
however crater stops this and kills
Balder exclaiming that he has stopped
the cycle this cycle refers to the fact
that the majority of gods throughout the
series have murdered their parents and
then went on to be murdered by their
children
Zeus attempted to kill Chronos Kratos
killed Zeus and bald heir is about to
kill Freya
once again dooming the guards to tragedy
Kratos wants a better life for his son
so he stops this unfortunately
Boulder's death hurls the Ragnarok
prophecy 100 winters forward
in the end of days for the Viking gods
this will hopefully be picked up in the
sequel to the game but for now it is
left ambiguous to exactly what
implications it could cause phase
prophecy and the traces true identity
revealed
upon entering your name Kratos a
notorious discover their story
prophesized in the runes of the
destroyed realm Fey Kratos his wife knew
that they were journey here and
discovered this story and their destiny
labeled us the story of Loki we learn
that a tree otters in fact the infamous
Norse god Loki is a shape-shifting God
that is known pass ability to conjure
tricks and fool people into thinking
certain ways it should be noted however
that the God of War mythology differs
heavily from the original myths so
whether this will be carried over until
the sequel is unknown it may be
interpreted differently by the creators
and put across in a certain way that
makes the original Loki character
difficult to associate fully with
Patraeus
another sequel teasin aspect is that one
of the tapestries appears to show at
Reyes murdering Kratos once again we
will have to wait until the sequel to
know for sure how this will play out
however it does once again him at the
cycle of death that horns Kratos and his
family Thor
another end credits scene happens if
players return home and rest doing so
will cause the game to leap forward one
year and T's Thor coming to see at Reyes
and Kratos
similar to how Balder did at the
beginning of the story obviously this
encounter carries a lot of weight to it
as Kratos murdered those sons earlier in
the adventure we are yet see Odin and
one could imagine that the sequel too
could involve Kratos tackling all of the
gods in brutal fashion similar to what
the original trilogy did with the
Grecian ones in conclusion there are
several interesting and ambiguous
aspects to the game's closing chapter
and all of them beautifully teased what
we could be getting in a sequel as
always I'd love to hear your thoughts on
the game's climax and if you think there
is anything that I've missed then please
let me know when the
if you enjoyed this video please like it
and subscribe to my channel as I do
ending explanations across a wide range
of media including movies TV and games I
also review graphic novels at my website
definition Caro UK so please check that
link in the description thanks very much
for taking the time to watch this video
I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]